[音楽]
いや1203じゃねぇ
8全233
女性に約30両洋1234
様子も零戦でしょなぜ204の色気
なんで237ああ
あーあさき無明の撮ってもらっていっ
まあいい
[音楽]
麺ヌくせーな家殺すぞ
ええええええ
masaki
今なんて言ったえっ
いいよって言ったよちゃんって聞いとけや
スクール
なんだ
これ
masaki
今日もかわいいよええ
止めている始めたあたりめーだろ
の日常式キー点でこのアホがー
[音楽]
dane
俺
これ人の心を読み取れるようにやってる
これは
使える
[音楽]
バッハすがりつき学位ってかっ
まーすってもいたよおいます開き
ジャンケンしようぜ
めんどくせーなー辛いはひとまず俺は今の能力を把握する必要がある
まずは手始めに瞬間的に相手の嗜好で看取る練習をしなければ少しずつこの動力をもの
にしていこう
そして目指すは世界征服だ
p あさあコイン ok 融通最初
じゃんけん
いいいいいああお前月をグーを出す直美と鈴パーでて目を焼き殺す
グリーン
嫁とはん
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ビアあああああ
言おう
なんだ
源さんの声とは別に何か聞こえた
なんだとエッ源さん
[音楽]
あれ
気のせいか
くっ
そう何も考えなければオネエにこの能力を築かれることはない吠えてるよはじめさあ
[音楽]
a
ん
[音楽]
何のことあぶねーばれるとこだった
全部聞こえてるっていうの
まさかっ
正木もこの能力を使えるのか
わかんないけど多分速実は俺もさっき使えるようになったら
まさかお前も使えるようになると残念だ聞かれたりゃー
そうだ心の声が読み取られるんだった
それにしても残念だ増えてるよ源さんどうするなこれ
わからない
がああ
俺はこの能力を使ってしたいことがあるんだしたいことあーあー
エロいことにも使ってみたいか
これは
世界征服をしたい
トイレ行きたいなぁなるほど
たぶん無理だがこのアホには聞こえてるぞ俺は本気だ
俺たち2人がこの能力を駆使すれば必ずこの世界の頂点を取ることができる気がするん
だこの人
マジだ
本気で世界征服をしようとしているなぁ俺も協力するそして最後は雅紀も頃すっごい
取るを
ん
me
バッハ